it's normalization I'll admit I you guys
know that me and etymology I'm really
keen to know what the meanings of words
are and on where they come from it
probably is some sensible benefits but I
haven't worked out what it is okay
so what does it mean to normalize a
database
what's the overarching goal of database
normalization here it is in a sentence
we want to make a database as efficient
as possible
the overarching goal the database
normalization is to increase database
efficiency as much as we can okay now
there are a few specific objectives that
get at that that make a database more
efficient okay so for example a typical
thing would be if you got say an address
and address let's think of say the
address of the school right now that's
17 to 31 Felton Road um Karl inferred
and what else can we put in here we
could put the state and we could also
put the postcode
okay and there's an address now you
could make one field out of this entire
piece of data okay but I would suggest
it's not very efficient it's not very
helpful to you okay um you know basic
reason you've got all these spaces in
between all these actual discreet
separate piece of data example you can
say the one piece might be the street
number right the street number that
would be one piece on its own then you
might have the street itself street name
and then you would have suburb stay and
postcode right now in between all of
these are you've got one two three four
five different sections different
separate piece of data you know these
spaces that actually go between there or
commas or whatever that you would use to
delineate these in the field so if this
is one field you're wasting these spaces
in here right so is the first thing
secondly if you want to search through
this you remember we're talking about
queries yesterday right well suppose you
wanted to find all the people who live
in one cup suburb right Khalif it okay
will be really tough to find that if
everything was one field okay you'd have
to say the address contains and then you
have to start using some wildcards
remember we talked about those yesterday
but you'd like address equals the
archive could start you know that would
be weird
right that is you just to say suburb
equals cut a leave it as a much more
efficient way to search through this
database so there's one of these
specific ways we can improve the
efficiency of a database and there are
other ones as well they'll come out as
we go through this example okay so I've
got an a Google spreadsheet here if you
want to open it up should look like this
okay now the important thing about this
is that there's a few different sheets
down the bottom here I want you to leave
off for now we're going to progress
through them okay and we're trying to
make the this database as a efficient as
we can we'll get more and more efficient
as we go so let's start have a look at
the database I hope you've got open
there and you can see well if you were
to name this database what would you
call it
what do you think it's about if you
wanted to name this table hmm it's got
information about customers but it's not
a customer table is it right it's
actually telling you lots of other
things that relate to you know a
different piece of data probably a
better thing would be purchases or
orders or invoices right so you can see
invoice number here this is the primary
key you see that right that's a that's
one of the ways you can tell what a
database is about what's the primary key
here invoice number is probably the best
primary key okay you can see they're
going sequentially down now you can see
there's some problems here number one
you've got this address business
happening which we already talked about
so it's I street addresses already is
you know I can break this up into a few
things but there's other problems too
can you notice over here on the right
hand side I've got quite a few what we
call repeated fields right so number one
we said you can make a database more
efficient by splitting up fields okay
into
as many sort of separate parts as you
can but number two this is a really
inefficient thing we want to get rid of
I've got product one unit cost one units
one and then I've got all three fields
repeated again and then all three fields
repeated again I assume because this guy
Fred right he bought three different
kinds of products at once so my database
needed to have three different sets even
though no one else has bought three but
I need these extra fields over here okay
so you can see all over here these spots
down here as well they're inefficient
there are a waste of space the database
has to have set aside space in the
database for these spots even if there's
no data that actually goes in there base
that's not very efficient so how can we
start to improve this well you might
want to move on to the next sheet here
this stands for first normal form ah
let's see how it's been approved number
one I've taken what used to be full name
I've broken it up into two you see how
it's a smart way to do things right
because usually if I want to get things
in some kind of order for names we don't
usually go firstly in alphabetical right
and in our initial database that's the
only option you've got so you see how
broken that apart firstable ask them
that's the first thing okay secondly you
can see I no longer have three copies of
these fields over here I don't have
product one unit cost one units one and
more of them over here I've just got
these three now because I've chopped off
this part if you like a vertically just
slice that off I don't want to lose the
data was over here so that's why now you
can see one two three rows three records
for Fred Smith now right and these
correspond to the three products that
you bought does that make sense
okay so what have I done I've broken up
this field here to two and then I've got
rid of these duplicate fields over here
getting rid of the duplicate field then
I had to add some more rows you okay but
who else can see a big glaring problem
is an improvement there's still some big
glaring problems with this database any
suggestion
you've got okay alright number one now
okay let's go with that if Fred had not
bought three products
suppose he bought 300 okay it'd have to
be three hundred rowers just for him
okay
now three hundred rows is not so bad die
they get a lot bigger than three hundred
I think the reason why it's such a pain
here is because every time I talk about
Fred I have to talk about Fred and his
dress right and those get copied every
time we seen leaves it this same place
all the time
I assume right so it'll be far more
efficient for me rather than having his
address here in this table that's really
about purchases right and make a whole
new table what would you call it the
customer table right so I'm going to
need to introduce a customer ID here
that talks about this customer and then
I don't have to repeat all of this
address information every time you can
also see if you pay attention over here
on the right the products as well right
you've got a similar issue with the
product say the the trinket okay cost
three dollars sixty five well cuz three
dollars 65 every time someone buys
someone sign one buys it right I got
this price room
sorry about that I'll fix that up in a
minute so I've got what we call
redundant data here do you remember that
redundant it's repeated it's just
duplicated for no good reason
and supposing you know in fact this is a
really good example that I've introduced
an error in here right the trigger does
a really cost $23 50 but I might not
notice that because I look at the other
place at the trigger cost right and I
don't have to look through all of the
odd versi are looks fine okay so not
just is it inefficient it brings in sort
of places for errors to creep in does
that make sense so let's try and improve
this a little further okay let's go to
the next sheet over what have we done
I've introduced two things in a sense
this tables worse than the previous one
but I'm getting there I've introduced a
customer ID okay so that's going to let
me describe Fred Mary it's
it okay I've also introduced a product I
did so in the next version of this
that's improving it right I won't need
to talk about Fred
I love mood Fred and Sue and Jack and so
on into a separate customers table I
will also improved all these products
and trinkets and wig worms right I'll
remove them into a separate I guess we
would call it up products table right so
for one flat file database I'm now going
to make a relational database with three
tables much more efficient okay so let's
move on
there we go that's looking pretty good
that's a big improvement now of course I
haven't included here the customers
database or the products database so you
can see what's replaced it right there's
my customer ID here's my Product ID if
someone for example are a customer moves
okay I only have to adjust their address
in one place rather than in like ten
places okay far more efficient there's
one more thing I can do to improve this
okay you can see here invoice number
order number and invoice date can you
see that these three fields are all what
we call functionally dependent on each
other there they're not just three
completely disconnected fields they're
actually related right and so these
three fields are a really good candidate
to make into a fourth table right so
this is my purchases or a invoice sorry
this is my purchases table right I'll
have a customers table a product table
and I'm going to introduce one more an
invoices table which will include this
data okay so finally from our original
database this is what I left with now
it's a bit harder to read this is a bit
harder to read to look at it and you
think oh I don't I don't know who this
is and I don't know what that is I don't
know how much it costs but the database
has it all tucked away in a far more
efficient form does that make sense so
this is a normalized database you can
see how it's much more efficient and
there's less redundant data